[Music]
how much money have you spent over the
years collecting cars is my wife gonna
hear this or is this just your wife will
not hate it okay maybe five hundred
thousand that's far too much your wife
harder I'm Oliver Devine and welcome to
car collectors New York
hello guys my name is richard willard
and welcome to vintage motorcars come on
in when I was about 23 and uncle had a
friend who he was doing he had an auto
body shop and he was restoring her car
and he couldn't do it anymore
and he asked me if I wanted to and then
I said yeah I'll take him until he's new
I was involved with cars and I restored
the car then he gave me another one and
another one and before I know it I was
in business and I was restoring cars for
people I've been collecting cars for
about 30 years the collection is
probably worth under 100 million dollars
this is my showroom this is where I keep
some of my more special cars and we also
some of the cars that we do have for
sale here collecting is really a very
personal thing and a lot of it has to do
with when you were growing up what you
remember and where you were from rich
pleasure to meet you sir
vintage motorcars this is you yes take
us through your cars the best of the
best I want to see what you got lovely
oh thank you it's a car this is the it
really is it's a gorgeous car the lines
on it I've owned this for about 30 years
I think when I bought this I think I
paid I think like around ten thousand
dollars for it and what would it go for
now
about six hundred thousand and this is
another piece called these did I think a
doughnut and there was different
different ornaments and that that
actually is a functional one where tell
you there's actually like a thermometer
in there I'll tell you the engine
temperature serious cause beautiful as
well yeah yeah it was a convertible
sedan which was pretty fancy that you
know it was sedan yet the the top went
down and it had windows all the way
around if they pulled up on Broadway in
this car getting yeah and I don't do
that that I would
[Music]
this is money I hear this is me if I if
I pictured me in a car that's a nice
little passenger seat someone driving me
it's not safe for you I think you should
seat Lee this was sitting around the
streets of New York I mean it could be
drunken this'll be fine what why you
suggesting I would be drunk just cuz I'm
brave this is where some of my more
unique cars are this particular car here
this is a 42 Chrysler Town and Country
again loaded with wood
well the unique things about this is
that this car finishes a quarter of a
million dollars you're kidding me yes
not a very common car it's a 34 Lincoln
was it common not nice guy fool this is
what maybe about 35 40 thousand range
yeah yeah he's got great house there's
guys and just collect hood ornaments
because there are very artistic and
everybody used to try and I'll do the
other guy with their hood ornaments
where I come from in South London
there's guys that collect hood ornaments
but they're not really artistic they
just feed oh okay yeah yeah rich thank
you for a great afternoon and for ever
giving me car any be for the rest of my
life oh thank you for coming I really
appreciate it was a pleasure to show you
around it's been a great afternoon at
vintage motorcars make sure you check
out the next episode of GQ car
collectors I'm gonna steal one of these
seriously guys let us know what your
favorite car is comment below and you
can tweet us as well
[Music]